Star Wars: The Last Jedi has come and gone.
The credits have rolled, the battles have
been fought, and there was more family drama
than you could shake a porg at.
But now that the movie's over, you've probably
got more than a few thoughts about just what
it all means.
Well, think no more: we're about to explain
the ending of The Last Jedi.
But before we begin, one last word of warning:
major spoilers ahead.
A Forceful conclusion
We got a glimpse at all kinds of Force-powered
shenanigans this time around.
From Rey and Kylo Ren staying up late to chat
on the Force-phone, to Snoke waving Rey around
like a rag doll, the Force has never gotten
used quite like this.
General Leia strapped on Force-fueled rocket
boosters and flew herself through actual outer
space!
That beats the hell out of Qui-Gon Jinn messing
around with a bunch of stupid dice.
But the true expression of the Force in this
movie came in the form of Luke Skywalker projecting
an illusion of himself across the galaxy to
fool Kylo Ren during their duel on Crait.
And when the fight was over and the Resistance
escaped, we saw Luke just … disappear.
If you're new to this whole Star Wars thing,
you're going to want to check out a little
film called A New Hope.
In that movie, Darth Vader swings his lightsaber
right through Luke's master, Obi-Wan Kenobi.
But instead of making a Kenobi-kabob, Obi-Wan
simply disappears, his robes falling to the
floor.
The same thing happened when Yoda passed away
in Return of the Jedi.
In both instances, the Jedi masters became
one with the Force, ultimately helping Luke
on his quest.
Now that Luke has pulled the same trick, it's
fair to say Rey will reap the benefits in
the same way going forward.
And it's a safe bet he'll show up as a Force
ghost in Episode 9, just like his little green
buddy did this time around.
Suffering from a Phasma attack
In an interesting twist, we got the return
of Captain Phasma, one of the most underutilized
characters from The Force Awakens.
She makes her return in The Last Jedi and
gets into a pretty neat fight with Finn.
And then he hits her in the face and she falls
down into a bunch of fire and disintegrates
or whatever.
It's impossible to know for sure, but it's
tough to imagine that Phasma will come back
for a third time in Episode 9.
The explosion she fell into looked pretty
gnarly overall, so even though she was wearing
all that fancy armor, she's probably gone
off to that big moisture farm in the sky.
In fact, now we know for sure just what role
Phasma plays in this new Star Wars trilogy:
she's the new Boba Fett.
You know, because she looks cool, seems important
— and then sucks real bad right before falling
into a hole and biting the big one in a lame,
pathetic way.
Bye, Captain Phasma.
Too bad you never got to, like, do anything.
Snoke and mirrors
Rumors about Snoke's true identity have been
floating around ever since he first appeared
in The Force Awakens, and we didn't get any
answers to that question here.
And despite getting sliced into chunks in
The Last Jedi, it's still possible for him
to pull things together and come back in the
next movie.
For starters, fans have long speculated that
Snoke is actually Darth Plagueis — the Sith
Lord who supposedly found a way to cheat death
itself.
The rumor became so inescapable that it's
even gotten several official denials.
But even if he's not Plagueis, if you look
at his face in the movie, it sure looks like
he's been cut up and put back together more
than a few times already.
Whoever he really is, he might be only mostly
dead.
Besides, there's ample evidence that being
hacked up with a lightsaber isn't as debilitating
as you might think.
The legend of Plagueis is one example.
Darth Maul was chopped in half, just like
Snoke, and fell down a giant hole in The Phantom
Menace…and he came back in the comics and
cartoons with robo-legs.
And what about Darth Vader?
He was chopped into bits, and burned to a
crisp by an actual volcano, and he still stuck
around for a bunch of movies after a quick
Hot Topic makeover.
This may not be the last we've seen of Snoke
at all…
The next Star War
Whether it's Ren who's in charge or some glued-together
Snoke, the First Order definitely has more
going for it than the Resistance, which is
down to its last members.
But the end of the film definitely implies
that the legend of Luke Skywalker is spreading.
Needless to say, the escape from Crait isn't
a victory for the Resistance, but it's likely
more than enough to spark some new recruits
to the rebel cause.
Poe's finally learned a thing or two about
how to be a leader, Finn has clear ideas about
when to fight and when to run, and Rey is
tapping into her true power, so maybe the
Resistance is actually in a better position
than it may seem.
One of the main ideas behind The Last Jedi
is that things are not always how they appear.
Luke fooled Ren, Ren fooled Rey, and Disney
fooled all of us into caring about Porgs.
"Porgs, which no one has actually seen in
action yet, but which will become an internet
phenomenon."
In the end, Rey had the right idea when she
said that the galaxy needs a legend—the
Battle of Crait may actually serve as a surprising
rallying cry for the Resistance to beef up
its ranks for the final showdown with the
First Order in Episode 9.
We'll just have to wait and see.
Rey's origins
Building off of that theme of deception and
legends, we got a pretty anticlimactic answer
to one of the most burning questions from
The Force Awakens: who are Rey's parents?
Episode 7 heavily implied that Han Solo knew
something about her...
"Who's the girl?"
Well, if Kylo Ren is to be believed, they're
a couple of nobodies who sold her for drinking
money.
Only, we've learned pretty conclusively that
Kylo Ren is not the most truthful guy.
He tricked Rey into turning herself over to
the First Order so she could turn him to the
Light.
Convincing Rey she's not actually important—except
to him as his partner in galactic conquest—falls
right in line with his overall goals and deceptive
character.
Just as Snoke might be able to pull himself
together in time for the final chapter in
this saga, it's also plausible that the subject
of Rey's mysterious parentage isn't quite
as closed as Kylo Ren—and writer-director
Rian Johnson—might want us to believe.
And who knows?
Maybe her mom is Captain Phasma!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too.